[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by jimmy simpson aka
spencer clay and the man who fell to
earth which premieres this sunday on
showtime at 10 a.m eastern how you doing
today jimmy sunday
this sunday we're in the future oh okay
we've traveled to the future oh wait
this isn't live
um thanks
for helping me understand how things
work i'm good how are you
i'm good man so
for a show like this did you actually go
and read the whole novel it's based off
of or watch the david bowie film to kind
of prep her do you kind of just know
that i walked everything out i just went
in cold in the dark had no idea of the
source material no i i knew i i knew the
uh the film i know the film i watched it
in the late 90s with my
my film
um
snobby guy who went to wesleyan you know
and told me everything i needed to watch
uh
i wouldn't say it it it
clicked all the way i was a big bowie
fan
you know the movie's kind of an
unconventional
structure there's no real completion
um but when i
went back and visited it for this script
i truly
was just i was wide open and i and i
loved
nicholas rogue's
take
on sci-fi and david bowie's
inhabitation of an alien i mean if
there's never really been a more
believable alien um
uh him and jeff bridges are the two
to the
the best and then chuatel and
bill show up and now we're on the next
level
um but yeah i
i adore the film and then i read the
book uh when we were filming
um
and i just love how
alex and jenny have
have made a 45 year later sequel
and it's so beautiful and it's like
chronologically correct it's narratively
correct and
what they
what they did is you know nicholas rogue
kind of was like
oh under the kind of microscope like
looking at
at what an alien might be and we're all
very much watching from afar
as he goes through his trials and his
downfall
and alex and jenny with this it was so
clear they were
inhabiting
the characters and you're with the alien
for the pilot you're you are chewitel
you're having that full experience as
him
and i think that's the major kind of
shift that they made
they really
respect the source material but they've
really allowed themselves to get deep
into the humanity and the emotional
quality of each of these characters and
the isolation each one of them is
feeling
and each one is separated from the rest
of the world in their own way
sure and i mean it's awesome hearing you
talk about the project and the character
and i think when people get excited
seeing you and stuff i feel like you're
someone who has like the midas touch
here with picking projects and now you
got pachinko out and you got these both
coming out week to week you're crushing
it is are you picky though with what
what roles you take that has to be part
of this right
yeah yes i mean um
[Music]
i i would just i prefer i'm not above
anything i i just like if i have the
options
um i would prefer to choose
a project
that
either moves the needle
a little bit
sociologically artistically
or that pushes me uh some somewhere i
haven't gone and that's just that's
pretty much all
those are my demands
for myself when i'm choosing a project
does it do any of that stuff
and and that it has luckily served me
well and
men fell to earth is no exception my
goodness i feel so grateful that i got
to be involved with such a an amazing
group of artists um from alex and jenny
to the entire cast and the crew and the
designers just knocked out of the park
so
yeah all of these people came here
knowing it was a bit special
um and so then they put their heart into
it and yeah they really asked for more
than that
no and i love that you're so
appreciative of other people around not
just the acting and
you have so many amazing acting credits
under your belt and your true vet with
it so i'm also wondering too do you ever
get the itch to write or direct ever
well i sure do uh i've i've written uh a
few screenplays i almost made one
i've written several uh
show pilots i sold one
um and you know most of my writing and i
also directed so the feature i was gonna
do you know i hadn't done a feature
before and so
when i was trying to sell to the
producers they're like well you have to
show us
something besides like a goofy short you
made with charlie day so i said okay how
about i make a new non-goofy short with
charlie day
and so i got charlie and adam scott
another friend uh to
to do a scene so
yeah i'm gearing up it's just like in
the past 10 years acting has really
gotten in the way of my my writing and
directing career sure sure
and so yeah um
and you know when you're when i i've
been really fortunate with a lot of
these roles and so
it's kind of tough to be like oh i'm
gonna put this on the back burner for a
minute but yeah it's coming yeah that's
exciting to hear i mean and look
all the simpson fanatics are watching
this interview ready to go so we got it
lined up this sunday show time yeah
buddy 10 a.m 10 p.m eastern showtime and
watching pachinko now as well jimmy
thank you so much for joining me today
and hope to talk to you in the future
thank you steve so much man what a
pleasure have a great day